we now go to our coronavirus coverage
today is the last day to get a vaccine
at cashman center
and staff were only giving out second
doses however you can still receive the
coronavirus vaccine at other large
sites like the convention center which
opened this drive-through yesterday
you can get the medicine there from 8 30
to 4 tuesday through saturday
the health district expects to give out
about a thousand vaccines at this
location per day
across clark county more than 1.4
million doses of the coronavirus vaccine
have been given out
less than half of our county has gotten
at least one shot so far and
statewide more than 2 million doses have
been administered
nevada is closing in on having 27
percent of the population fully
vaccinated
now here's a quick look at the
coronavirus numbers at the latest
report from the state are positivity
rate it is unchanged now it's been that
way for more than a week it's 5.7
percent
as you see on your screen 373 new cases
added to the state totals
and unfortunately seven more deaths most
of these cases and deaths are from here
in clark county where most of the state
lives
and the recovery rate has been basically
the same just under 96 percent